- Mmm!
- (man) Oh, whoa.
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo,
yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Hold up now. Hold up now.
Hold up, man.
You gonna continue to eat the froyo
even on top of the brain freeze?
What are you doing, dog?
- Mmm!
(relaxing music)
- (narrator) ♪ (unintelligible)
(intense music)
- Good evening, St. Paul.
It's your city news at five.
I'm Jamie Thronberg.
- And I'm Marcy Whitchurch.
Winter weather advisories are
in effect across central
Minnesota tonight,
with more on that,
weatherman Isaac Liboda.
Isaac.
- Thanks, Marcy.
A major system is zipping
across the region.
Outside temp right now eight degrees
but it feels like 20 below.
Jamie.
- Well stay off the roads if you can,
folks, lots of reports of black ice.
- Ooh. You gotta watch out
for that dangerous black ice.
It's transparent and sneaky.
Hard to see black ice.
- That's right, Marcy.
Keep your loved ones safe
and warn them to stay
off the streets tonight
because of menacing,
life-robbing, black, black ice.
- Isaac.
- We have Channel 17's field reporter
Darren Hempner with more. Darren.
- Yeah...
I'm standing out here
in historic Ramsey Hill where
there are currently no cars
on the street due to,
uh...hazardous driving conditions.
- Darren, are you talking about black ice?
- That's right!
- Ooh Jesus. It's frightening
just to even say black ice.
- It's scary, tricky, ruthless
stuff, that black ice.
A perfectly safe neighborhood
can be suddenly terrorized
by the appearance of black ice.
- Well...one must keep in mind that
just because black ice looks
different than white ice
it doesn't make it any more dangerous.
Also, one must remember how hard it is
for black ice to survive what with
the authorities trying to destroy it
with the snowplows and the salt trucks
but black ice perseveres.
- That's right! That's right!
And as you can see right now,
the city is being controlled
by lots of oppressive white snow
making it hard for all people to advance!
And we don't hear much news
about that now, do we?!
- No we do not!
- Well, thank you very
much, brother Darren.
- But let's be honest, black
ice is the real menace.
Last night I was in a
perfectly safe neighborhood
walking away from an ATM
machine when black ice just
snuck up on me and practically
robbed me of my balance.
- Ouch. That sounds exactly like
something black ice would do.
- Well I just hope that folks watch out
so the white snow doesn't
blind them and keep them
from seeing what's really going on!
- All I'm saying is I can't
think of a single Christmas song
about black ice. Lots of
cheerful, uplifting songs
about snow, so.
- (chuckles sarcastically)
Well, for the record, black ice
never asked to be out here!
- No, it did not!
- It's a product of the environment!
- Woo! Hallelujah!
- In fact, black ice
didn't land on the road!
The road landed on black ice!
- Woo! Amen!
(uplifting music)
- Okay...next up.
Why is America being
ruined by black people?
(intense music)
(lighthearted music)
- ♪ Would you look at the time ♪
- ♪ You should just stay here tonight ♪
- ♪ I've had too much wine ♪
- ♪ You could leave at first light ♪
- ♪ It isn't that far ♪
- ♪ Baby, just stay where you are ♪
- ♪ Back to my place ♪
- ♪ You can't escape from my embrace ♪
- ♪ I really had a very nice time ♪
- ♪ Let me just refill that wine ♪
- ♪ But I really need
to just say goodbye ♪
- ♪ I would love to see you try ♪
- ♪ Please unlock this door ♪
- ♪ It's locked from the outside ♪
- ♪ I cannot stay tonight ♪
- ♪ Baby, you're mine tonight ♪
- ♪ Look, I really have to go ♪
- ♪ No, you really have to stay ♪
- ♪ Hey, no means no ♪
- ♪ That is what they all say ♪
- ♪ You're hurting my arm ♪
- ♪ I won't cause you any harm ♪
- ♪ Let go of me ♪
- ♪ We can make this hard or just easy ♪
- ♪ A woman always comes prepared ♪
- ♪ Ooh, I'm really scared ♪
- ♪ I said this is not what I want ♪
- ♪ Why you have to be such a ♪
- ♪ I know self-defense ♪
- ♪ I dare you to try it ♪
- ♪ I don't wanna fight. ♪
- ♪ Bitch, you are mine tonight ♪
(smack)
(smacking)
- Ah!
- (crying) Please just please go away!
- ♪ I thought that you wanted me to stay ♪
- Well, I just changed my mind!
- ♪ I think I'll just stay and unwind ♪
- How did this (unintelligible) switch?
- ♪ Now you are my bitch ♪
(smack)
- Please just be kind tonight!
- ♪ Now you're mine tonight ♪
(cartoon honk)
- You sold me out, son.
Now you gonna end up with a
bullet in your head for it.
- You can't play me mother (bleep).
(escalating music)
I'm the mother (bleep)
that plays mother (bleep)s mother (bleep).
- (Jim) Cut.
(bell ringing)
(clears throat)
- (man) All right everybody,
let's get reset, we are going again.
- (Jim) (sighs)
Nigel. That's great.
- (British accent) Oh,
great. It's smashing.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, well, it's been an absolute honor
and what a great opportunity to be here
and be able to play an American tough.
- Well, I'm just so glad
that we got you outta
that BBC commitment so you
can play with us. (laughs)
- (Nigel) Cheers, mate. Cheers. Cheers.
- Antoine, listen, I'm
just not buying that
you're someone that was born and raised
in the streets of Brooklyn.
- That's weird 'cause I actually was born
and raised on the streets of Brooklyn.
I was in a gang and everything.
Most of this stuff
actually happened to me.
- Wow. Okay. Well, that's great for us
'cause I want you to use it. Okay?
Good first take, let's
just, let's get going.
Let's go, let's get going.
- (Nigel) Thank you, Jim.
- (clears throat)
- Scene five, take two.
(click) (bell ringing)
- (Jim) And action!
(escalating music)
- You sold me out, son.
Now you gonna end up with a
bullet in your head for it.
- You can't play me mother (bleep).
I'm the mother (bleep)
that plays mother (bleep)s mother (bleep).
- (sighs) Cut. Cut.
(bell ringing)
(clears throat) Okay.
Nigel, that was great.
- (Nigel) Oh!
Brilliant. Just the way you
move, especially when you talk.
I just really see this character
coming to life before
my eyes. It's fabulous
- (Nigel) Cheers, mate, cheers
- It's fabulous. Antoine,
your performance,
it's just not quite there yet, okay?
I really need to see you make
more of a transformation.
Okay? Like Nigel here.
- That dude's British.
- Yeah.
- Antoine, if I might jump
in with a bit of advice.
- I don't think I need that.
- No, no, no, no. Look, hear him out.
- Maybe you might want to try thinking of
something in the material that's similar
to something that's
happened in your real life.
- (Jim) Mmm!
- For me, for instance, I like
to think of when (chuckles)
me mum wanted me to attend prep school
in Leeds to become a barrister,
but I wanted to study
the theater at Oxford.
- Thank God.
- And so that was a
conundrum, really, for me.
- I'm gonna stop you right, right there.
'Cause this, it's just
confusing me, right?
Like, I don't need that
'cause I am from the streets.
I was in a gang.
They told me to kill my cousin.
- Might be a bit spot on, no?
- Yeah, it's a bit spot on.
Do you have any stories
that involve your mum?
- What's a mum?
- Oh dear.
- Scene five, take three.
(click) (bell ringing)
- (Jim) Okay, Antoine,
remember, you're a gangster.
Okay? Betrayal, the streets.
Okay? Nigel, you're
perfect, Antoine, transform.
And action!
(escalating music)
- You sold me out, son.
Now you gonna get a bullet
up in your head for it.
- You can't play me mother (bleep).
I'm the mother (bleep)
that plays mother
(bleep)s, mother (bleep)!
- He's boring to watch.
(sighs) Cut.
(bell ringing)
- That does not sound good.
- (sighs) Antoine. I do not feel like
you have found the emotional
core of this character!
- Man, (bleep) this! Nobody
is more real than me!
Okay? I come from the streets!
And nobody's gonna tell me
what the streets is like.
Nobody! You understand?! (sighs)
- That's a great speech, I
just wish that I believed it.
You wanna give it a shot?
- Sure, I'll have a go.
Man, (bleep) this. I'm as real as it gets!
- (Jim) Yes.
- This (bleep)ing streets is for real,
I'm up in there, man!
- (Jim) You are.
- I'm (bleep)ing from
the, from the (bleep)ing
from the Earth, from these streets.
- (Jim) From the Earth.
- Something to that effect.
- And that, no, but I'm so with you!
I'm with you when you say that,
even when you're saying the wrong words!
I just wish you could do that!
- You know what?
- (groans, coughs)
- (Nigel) Oh goodness.
- Okay, that hurts, but
I don't feel that it
comes from the right emotional
place for the character.
All right? Here, give it a shot.
Give me. Watch, watch.
(groans, coughs)
Oh, that's, that's great.
- I feel that in here
- (Nigel) Thank you.
and in here
- (Nigel) That's very
gracious of you to say that.
- in my heart. Try that again.
(groans, coughs)
- (choking) I just, I don't believe you.
- What flavor you got?
- Vanilla. What flavor'd you got?
- Lemon zinger.
- Lemon zinger like that tea?
- Ooh.
Oh no.
- (man) What's going on?
- (sucks in) I got that brain freeze.
- Oh man, the fuck you do.
You ain't got no brain freeze.
- Ooh! (hisses and growls)
- Hey, dude, relax, man.
That shit'll pass man.
Calm down.
- It ain't passin'.
(groans) It's intensifyin'.
- (man) What do you mean it's not passin'?
(unintelligible) It can't
be intensifyin', dog.
- Ooh! (hisses)
- Come on, man, you say
you from the hood, dog.
You acting weak right now
with this brain freeze.
- (groans) Ah!
- Come on. Ain't no brain freeze gonna
make you yell like that, man. Get over-
- (exhales)
- Don't be hitting your head
with the brain freeze, come on, hey.
Yo, you goin' silver balls on it?
Silver balls on the
straight kinetic energies.
- (inhales, vocalizes)
- (man) What's wrong with you?
Come on, okay Exorcist.
- (vocalizes)
- (man) What you doing now?
What, you doing some kung fu?
Get over it, man.
- (continues vocalizing)
- Listen, it can't be
doing this much to you.
Listen, man, don't be
a punk-ass bitch, man.
Get over the br-
What, are you afraid
now, you seein' things?
You just scared? The brain
freeze making you scared.
- (vocalizing) Who are you?
- What do you mean who am I?
You ain't got no Alzheimer's.
What's wrong with you?
- (yelling)
- You a punk-ass bitch.
What is this?
You goin' all Three Stooges
on this motherfucker.
This is some craziness.
- (continues yelling)
- Oh, you did the hand block.
You know what man, you're weak, man.
You a weak-ass motherfucker,
that's the problem
is you put-
- Mmm!
- Oh whoa, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo,
yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Hold up now. Hold up now.
Hold up, man.
- Ooh!
- You gonna continue to eat the froyo
even on top of the brain freeze?
- (vocalizes)
- What are you doin', dog?
Hey, now I really startin'
to respect you now, man.
If you gonna eat the thing
that's causing you the pain?
This is crazy. Oh, now it's going faster!
He's speeding up!
You're staring into the brain freeze.
This shit is straight
crazy right here, dog.
Hey, real talk though, real talk though.
Real talk though.
I mean, it's crazy, that time, man, that
I strangled Benny with my bare hands
'cause he didn't have my money.
- All right. We got him.
- Got who?
What?
What, you Five-O?
- Stand up slowly.
- (man) Who-?
I can't believe this, man,
I've known you since sixth grade.
- You under arrest for the
murder of Benny Techderatrix
Get him outta here.
- Hey man, you a punk-ass
brain freeze motherfucker.
- You going to jail for
a long time. (groans)
In too deep. (inhales)
Ah, I got that brain freeze.
I got caught with the brain freeze.
- (man) Yeah, you got that brain freeze.
- Get him outta here.
(calm music)
- (narrator) ♪ All I wanted
♪ But I don't need ♪